[Applause]
[Music]
guys this is a very special episode of
new releases and not just because I'm
gonna tell you to say no to drugs for
the first time in this show's history we
get to talk about a Super Nintendo game
but hey who knows hit that subscribe
button and maybe we'll get to talk about
another one in a future episode for now
here are some of the biggest games
dropping this week also don't do drugs
kids it's not really fair to call the
series a cult classic anymore but
danganronpa v3 killing harmony continues
to up the ante of high school drama and
murder yes apparently that's still
possible v3 has new mass panic debates
during its class trial segments making
it harder to pick out true statements
with everyone yelling over each other
there are also new minigames to help
literally spell out answers or reveal
images you can go back to school on ps4
Vita and PC on Tuesday September 26 real
talk guys I don't know much about total
war Warhammer - at all luckily this show
has a great UK correspondent who does so
I'm gonna throw it to mr. Dave Jewett
for more thanks Tony I'll take this
since I'm the game spot we'll hominoid
total war Warhammer 2 is obviously the
second entry to the total war Warhammer
series and while things are pretty weird
in the first game in its sequel they're
really embracing the most far-fetched
factions you've got a race of lizard men
who ride dinosaurs into battle and
they're led by a giant frog called a
slam that floats around the world
casting spells for high elves who are
basically the super posh race of more
Hammer who think they're better than
everyone but do have cool son dragons
pretty towers so they're not that bad
the Dark Elves who are basically
sadistic torturing raiding pyro elves
who go around murdering and slaving all
so they can power their magic floating
fortress all the while wearing bikini
armor and my favorites the Skaven who
are clowns of steampunk style rat people
who invent strange machines powered bike
big green crystals burrow into kingdoms
and eat all their inhabitants literally
just because they were hungry I'm going
to be doing a full faction guide video
in a couple of weeks so make sure you
subscribe for that
why did I leave my paints thanks Dave
those rats sound pretty gross and you
can try the mount along with all the
other factions on PC on Thursday the
28th paints not included now let's go
way back to the cartoon animation of the
30s because that's exactly what cuphead
looks like it's part contra part boss
rush all gorgeous each level has
branching paths so you might not fight
the same grinning pirate or evil
sunflower every time and you can take
them on with a friend who'll take
control of Cup heads pal mug man the two
of you can also explore an overworld
between levels to look for fun secrets
you can get your hands on Cup head on
Xbox one and PC on Friday the 29th and
now for your sports break FIFA 18 has
two big things in common with last
year's release it runs on EA's frostbite
engine and it continues Alex hunters
story in the journey mode Ultimate Team
legends are also back in the ps4 Xbox
one and PC versions of the game though
they're now called Ultimate Team icons
in any case you'll still have tons of
stadiums and teams to play around with
FIFA 18 comes to ps4 ps3 Xbox one Xbox
360 PC and Nintendo switch on Friday the
29th finally let's leave the stadiums
behind for some spaceships here we are
in 2017 and starfox 2 is finally getting
a proper release an incomplete and
definitely not legal version of the game
has been floating around for a while but
this is the proper sequel with a freely
explorable lylat system and a split
screen mode for dueling your friends
unfortunately right now you'll only be
able to get your hands on it as a pack
in game for the SNES classic which goes
on sale Friday the 29th man Nintendo
really needs to get moving on that
switch Virtual Console and those are
some of the hottest games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with our first batch of October new
releases next week